it's a huge honor to be back here
because I kind of feel like this is
where my spider-man journey sort of
kick-started you know and and it feels
like only yesterday that I was here
announcing the title and now it's
amazing to be here debuting the trailer
and it's just I'm so proud of this movie
and everyone that was involved
I'm so proud for them for what they have
achieved and I'm just excited for people
to see a little bit more of what we've
done this is a very different take on
spider-man this is something we haven't
seen before I'm obviously a lot younger
so we can really play on the youthful
side of the character we've seen the
soldier we've seen the billionaire we've
seen the gods and now it's time to see
the kid you know and I think it's fun to
see what would happen if you gave us 15
year-old superpowers and I think what
would happen is you have a pretty great
time one of the main reasons why people
love Peter Parker and spider-man so much
is that you can relate to him you know
there's there's not a person on this
planet who doesn't go through something
that Peter Parker goes through whether
it's struggling with homework talking to
girls being late for school or having
bigger responsibilities outside of
school and I think especially for young
kids it's a great thing to be able to
see a superhero go through the same
things that you're going through day to
day you know it's very reassuring that
it doesn't just happen to you it also
happens to superheroes
I mean it's not do die breathing it
still doesn't feel real to me now you
know everyone keeps asking me what it's
like working with Robert and was one of
the most surreal experiences of my whole
career even watching the trailers now I
can't quite comprehend that that's
actually me but but the fact that this
has actually come true and that this was
such a big dream of mine is it is crazy
and I can't quite believe I'm standing
here today I think that's what John and
Marvel and Sony did so well was create a
very unique character in a sense he's
just an average guy you know John said
the other day if a regular kid can
become a superhero why can't a regular
guy become a supervillain and you have
the scientist the billionaire aliens
monsters gods all sorts of villains but
now we just have you know a guy who
wants to stand up front often doesn't
really agree what's happening in society
and I think it's very interesting to see
a movie of such a big scale on such a
grounded level it's mind-blowing man
it's really something that I'm still
getting used to and it hasn't sunk in
yet and I think it'll be wrong if it
had something you know to be here today
I know I've said it is such an honor and
I'm so delighted and obviously realize
how lucky I am to be here but I'm but
the cost we couldn't have asked for a
better cost I mean John did such a great
job with casting all the kids and all
the big cheeses that we've got at the
top I mean I couldn't have been luckier
so I'm very happy you know Michael
Keaton was an active you I've always
looked up to he is someone who has such
an incredible career and platform behind
him and it was definitely intimidating
working with someone like him but so
refreshing because he's just such a nice
guy you know Michael is someone who you
can approach and sit down on set with
and have a have a good chat with and
also he has so much great advice to give
there's nothing more exciting than
having spider-man join the Marvel
Cinematic Universe we got a taste of
that last year in Captain America Civil
War I think many ways he stole the movie
and now we get to see his first
standalone feature in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
and that's something that that we geeked
out about very hard when Stan Lee and
Steve Ditko created spider-man over 50
years ago so brilliant about it well so
unique about it was here we had this
universe full of heroes and suddenly
they added to it this kid who had to be
home had a curfew had to do his homework
had to take care of his aunt he wasn't
living on another planet or living in an
ivory tower he was just a kid like most
of us are or were any had relatable
issues he had these unbelievable powers
he had great responsibility ah but he
had everyday issues and all of the great
Marvel characters have flaws have quirks
have something that makes them relatable
none have something as relatable as
Peter Parker does you know the vulture I
think is the second villains by the ever
face in the comics never been in a film
before and what was exciting to us about
it is we had this whole idea of what
would be like to actually live in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe we've made 15
movies now set within the same shared
continuity of universe and now we've
introduced spider-man to it we can
introduce some of his villains and what
does it like to grow up in that world
was it like to be in a world where you
can look over your head and Iron Man
flies by or aliens part of the city and
the Avengers come in attack them it
would be scary it would be exciting
certainly for Peter he got to spend some
time with the Avengers we saw him in
Civil War had a pretty amazing summer
vacation now he has to go back to high
school after hanging out with
with these rock stars what's that like
that's his journey the journey is
different for for Adrian Toomes the
vulture he is just a normal guy he's a
regular guy he lives in this world and
suddenly all these unbelievable things
are happening and he starts to feel
small so he starts to gather and
scavenge all of this amazing technology
that is left behind after these
superhero battles and he builds this
unbelievable wingsuit and he starts a
business of his own and it's fun to see
somebody that didn't just have you know
some sort of some sort of medical
accidents that led to that led to
superpowers we get to see him Richards
own two hands build his future and build
his destiny which is very much what he
believes it and Michael Keaton joining
the Marvel Cinematic Universe is also
one of those it was on the bucket list
he's an amazing persona he's an amazing
actor and getting to see him sort of
look and scowl at these at these heroes
and he thinks for someone ridiculous at
these names they're calling themselves
and he decides if you can't beat them
join them and he becomes this villain on
his own so at every turn in this movie
you see new aspects of spider-man that
have never been in a film before but had
been in the comics for years he's got
mechanical web-shooters as we saw in
Civil War he has to have web fluid if he
runs out he falls off a building so you
get some added tension there you get his
scientific smarts as he tries to figure
out ways out of that scenario it's the
first full spider-man of film that takes
place in highschool and he's got other
high school friends and for the very
first time somebody learns a secret and
he's got a best friend he's not sure he
can keep his mouth shut but his friend
Ned has learned his secret early on the
film and suddenly have an entirely new
dynamic for spider-man as he needs to
not only navigate the homework helping
his aunt doing what he thinks he needs
to do to impress Tony Stark he thinks he
should be an Avenger and not his best
friend Ned knows a secret
he's not going to be able to keep a lid
on it or is Ned going to be an ally he's
he getting help it's really exciting I
mean I feel guilty because we're still
finishing up the movie I just have a lot
of work to do but it's really exciting
to be here and I can't wait to show the
trailer on the massive screen as a fan
myself
I always wanted to make a movie that
showed what the MCU would look like from
a ground level perspective and now I get
to do that through Peter Parker's eyes
so there's going to be so many things
for
for for fans to be looking out for
throughout I've been especially relate
to Peter right now because in the movie
he's been given this amazing opportunity
by Tony Stark and he's just trying
really hard to prove himself so that you
could become an Avenger and not screw up
and that's exactly how I feel at every
moment making this movie so I think
there's this universal idea behind Peter
Parker just being a regular kid that you
can always relate to Tom's great because
he's so um there's just the greatest
sort of natural empathy where you just
feel for him and you can see what he's
going through in his face and he just
has this very relatable quality and also
he can just do a backflip so like he is
spider-man to me when Kevin Feige and I
saw John Watson ooby we knew that he was
the guy to direct this movie and we saw
a quality in him that has panned out so
brilliantly that I think everybody's
going to see when they see this movie
because it's very different than our
other spider-man films and it is
completely unique and so much of that is
due to the vision that he came in with
he's a really formidable filmmaker and
it's we were very lucky that he wanted
to do the film one of the things that I
think is so amazing about this
experience is that you don't have
studios deciding to work together to
make a film very often in fact it may
never happen again after we do the
sequel because Sony and gives me and
Marvel all decided that the right thing
to do was to allow Peter Parker and
spider-man to be in the MCU and to and
to work with the Marvel guys and have
them produce this film and I think that
was a very rare thing for three
companies to do and a very brilliant
thing for them to decide to do because
there are only so many stories that you
know you can tell again and again and
again about about Spidey and this is
something that we would have never been
able to do in any other way so it was a
very selfless thing that was
very smart on the part of all companies
you